Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright should
be reminded that victims of SCP-217 are not
toys, nor are they to be used as props at
a Steampunk Convention.
SCP-217, also known as the Clockwork Virus,
is a terrifying anomalous pathogen that slowly
converts the organic material of its victims
into analog mechanized elements, eventually
leaving them looking like inoperative steampunk
nightmares.
Of course, Dr. Bright has no permanent body,
and thus, it wouldn’t really hold much of
a threat for him.
Therefore, he could, in theory, start treating
the infected individuals like big, strange
robotic toys, but for the sake of human decency,
the O5 Council would really, really, really
prefer that he didn’t.